film une chose est sûre tout a changé
brutalement très brutalement quelques
mois dans cette affaire avec bien sûr
d'abord l'assassinât de bernard laroche
par jean marie villemin
mais il apparaît également que christine
villemin a elle aussi beaucoup changé
hervé brusini c'est vrai qu'elle a
changé et christine villemin
aujourd'hui elle semble inébranlable
presque dur chaque jour à la une de
l'actualité
sa silhouette noire traqué par la presse
sans répit aucun à 25 ans christine
villemin est si différente de ce qu'elle
était il y a à peine oui moi même qui
criait sa douleur à l'enterrement du
petit grégory dans la foule
les gendarmes sont là pour eux aucun
doute l'assassin de l'enfant assistent à
la cérémonie tout le monde est suspect
alors comment savoir
première piste pour les enquêteurs les
lettre d'un corbeau
l'une d'elles revendique le meurtre
toute la famille qui pratiquent souvent
le coup de griffe anonyme passe à la
dictée cette première expertise désigne
bernard laroche
mais elle est annulée vice de forme
alors on recommence cette fois christine
villemin est mise en cause
christine qui est en clinique ici même
enceinte elle a perdu l'un des jumeaux
qu'elle attendait pourtant le juge
lambert vient à son chevet lui faire
subir une nouvelle dictée est à nouveau
christine et désigner les experts ne
sont toujours pas sûrs de leur fait
encore des dictées pour christine et
trois autres personnes
si ce qu'on a fait réécrire
on a les mêmes qu'à ces questions
lorsque mon expertise contre expertise
on n'en finit pas de confronter
l'écriture de christine à ces lettres
est toujours la même réponse des
spécialistes à 80% nous sommes sûrs
qu'elle les a écrites
ces quatre femmes pensent la même chose
ce sont les collègues de travail de
christine elle affirme l'avoir vue
devant la poste au jour et à l'heure
même de la disparition de grégory le 16
octobre 84
christine nie tout cela elle se trompe
dit elle c'est la veille que j'étais là
bas le 15 pas le 16 et puis la mise en
faut se fait plus lourde
la police judiciaire à présent chargé de
l'enquète parle d'une cordelette
retrouvées au domicile des films une
cordelette qui serait en tout point
semblable à celle utilisée pour ligoter
l'enfant le jour du crime
le juge comme la police ne font rien
pour stopper ces rumeurs sourde
ils font de christine l'assassin de son
propre fils
sur ce choc je combats en a pris mon
gamin picone hamouma rmi-rsa toujours un
trait mois et pique ça j'ai rien à me
reprocher mais aujourd'hui jean-marie
n'est plus à ses côtés jean marie
l'homme qui décide
celui qui ira jusqu'à tuer bernard
laroche jean marie est en prison ressine
affirme qu'elle le soutient totalement
et qu'il lui fais totalement confiance
pour elle leur couple est sans faille
pourtant à la prison christine seront
tous les deux jours jean marie va mal on
la vit suicider et christine aussi parle
de mort si je suis incarcéré dit elle je
ferai une grève de la faim
le juge aura mon deuxième enfant sur la
conscience elle est farouchement
déterminés
christine villemin